ยินดีต้อนรับกลับสู่ความเข้าใจเรื่องข้อมูลควอนตัมและการคำนวณ ฉันชื่อ John Watrous และเป็นผู้อำนวยการฝ่ายเทคนิคด้านการศึกษาที่ IBM
Quantum นี่คือบทเรียนที่ 15 ของซีรีส์ และเป็นบทเรียนที่สามของ unit ที่สี่ ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ quantum error
correction จนถึงตอนนี้เราได้เห็นตัวอย่างบางส่วนของ quantum error correcting codes รวมถึง 9-qubit Shore
code, 7-qubit Steane code และ 5-qubit code และเราพูดถึง stabilizer formalism ด้วยซึ่งให้
mathematical foundation ที่เราสามารถอธิบายและวิเคราะห์สิ่งเหล่านี้และ quantum error correcting codes อื่นๆ อีกมากมาย
codes ที่ฉันพึ่งพูดถึงนั้นน่าสนใจอย่างแน่นอนและเป็นจุดเริ่มต้นธรรมชาติสำหรับ
การสำรวจ quantum error correction ปัญหาคือพวกมันสามารถทนต่อ error rate ที่ต่ำมากเท่านั้น
การแก้ error บน 1 qubit จาก 5, 7 หรือ 9 ตัวไม่เลว แต่น่าจะอย่างน้อยตามที่เราคาดไว้
เราจำเป็นต้องทนต่อ errors มากกว่านั้นมากเพื่อทำให้ large-scale quantum computing เป็น
ความจริง ในบทเรียนนี้เราจะดู quantum error correcting code constructions ที่ซับซ้อนกว่า เป็นครั้งแรก รวมถึง codes ที่สามารถ
ทนต่อ error rate ที่สูงกว่าอันที่เราเห็นมาก และถูกมองว่าเป็น promising candidates สำหรับ quantum error correction ใน
physical devices จริงๆ นี่คือภาพรวมสั้นๆ ของบทเรียน เราจะเริ่มด้วย class ของ
quantum error correcting codes ที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ CSS codes ตั้งชื่อตามนักวิจัยที่ค้นพบครั้งแรก ได้แก่ Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor และ Andrew Steane CSS code construction ช่วยให้ใช้คู่ของ classical
error correcting codes บางอย่างและรวมเข้าด้วยกันเป็น quantum error correcting code เป็นส่วนหนึ่งของการพูดถึงนั้น เรา
จะดู classical linear codes อย่างค่อนข้างรวดเร็ว และเราจะพูดถึง basic properties บางอย่างของ CSS
codes ส่วนที่สองของบทเรียนเกี่ยวกับ code ที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ toric code ซึ่งเป็นตัวอย่างที่พื้นฐานและ
สวยงามจริงๆ ของ quantum error correcting code ที่สามารถทนต่อ error rate ที่ค่อนข้างสูง จริงๆ แล้ว
toric code ไม่ใช่ตัวอย่างเดียวของ quantum error correcting code แต่มันเป็น infinite family ของ codes หนึ่ง
สำหรับแต่ละ positive integer เริ่มจากสอง และในช่วงสุดท้ายของบทเรียน เราจะพูดถึงสั้นๆ เกี่ยวกับ code families อื่นๆ บางส่วน
รวมถึง surface codes ซึ่งเชื่อมโยงอย่างใกล้ชิดกับ toric code รวมถึง
color codes ผู้คนศึกษา classical error correcting codes มาตั้งแต่ทศวรรษ 1940
และมันเป็นหัวข้อที่น่าสนใจและ rich มาก linear codes อาจเป็น classical error
correcting code ชนิดที่ง่ายที่สุด และฉันจะอธิบายว่าคำว่า linear หมายความว่าอะไรในบริบทนี้ในอีกครู่ แต่ง่าย
อย่างหนึ่งในการแสดงว่ามันคืออะไรคือมันเป็น stabilizer codes ที่บังเอิญเป็น classical และเราจะเห็นในไม่ช้าว่า
CSS codes โดยพื้นฐานเป็นคู่ของ classical linear codes ที่รวมเข้าด้วยกันเพื่อสร้าง quantum error
correcting code ดังนั้นเพื่อการพูดถึงนั้น เราจำเป็นต้องเข้าใจ basic things บางอย่างเกี่ยวกับ
classical linear codes ก่อน เราจะ take Sigma เป็น binary alphabet สำหรับ
การพูดถึงทั้งหมดนี้ และตอนนี้เมื่อเราอ้างถึง classical linear code เราหมายถึง set C ของ binary strings ความยาว n สำหรับ
positive integer n บางตัว ที่ satisfy แค่ basic property เดียว ซึ่งก็คือถ้า u และ v เป็น binary strings ใน C แล้ว string
u XOR v ก็อยู่ใน C ด้วย โดยวิธีที่นี่ u XOR v หมายถึง bitwise exclusive or ของ u และ v แค่
เหมือนที่เราเห็นหลายครั้งในบทเรียนที่ห้าและหกในส่วน quantum algorithms ของซีรีส์ และนี่คือสิ่งที่หมาย
ความว่าสำหรับ classical code ที่จะเป็น linear โดยพื้นฐานเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ binary strings ความยาว n ว่าเป็น n-dimensional vectors
ที่ entries ทั้งหมดเป็นศูนย์หรือหนึ่ง แต่แทนที่จะเป็น ordinary vector addition บน real หรือ complex
numbers เราใช้ addition modulo 2 ซึ่งก็แค่ XOR ดังนั้นถ้าเรามี
code words สองตัวคือ u และ v ซึ่งหมายความว่า u และ v เป็น binary strings ใน C แล้ว U บวก v modulo 2 หรือกล่าวอีกนัยหนึ่ง u XOR
V ต้องเป็น code word ใน C ด้วย และโดยวิธีนัยหนึ่งนี้ต้องเป็นจริงแม้ว่า U เท่ากับ V ไม่มีอะไร
ขัดขวางความเป็นไปได้นั้น และนั่นหมายความว่า classical linear code ทุกตัวต้องมี all zero string เพราะ
bitwise XOR ของ string ใดๆ กับตัวมันเองคือ all zero string ตัวอย่างเช่น 3-bit
repetition code เป็น classical linear code โดยเฉพาะมีสองตัวเลือกที่เป็นไปได้สำหรับ u และสองตัวเลือกที่เป็นไปได้
สำหรับ v และมันค่อนข้าง trivial ในการผ่าน pairs ที่เป็นไปได้เพื่อเห็นว่าเราได้ code word เสมอเมื่อ take bitwise
XOR นี่คืออีกตัวอย่างที่เรียกว่า [7,4,3] Hamming code นี่เป็นหนึ่งในตัวแรกที่สุดของ classical error
correcting codes ที่เคยถูกค้นพบ และประกอบด้วย binary strings 16 ตัวความยาวเจ็ด มีตรรกะง่ายๆ มาก
เบื้องหลังการเลือก strings เหล่านี้ แต่ฉันจะไม่อธิบายใน video นี้ และควรบอกด้วยว่าบางครั้งคุณจะเห็น strings เหล่านี้กลับด้าน แต่
ตอนนี้ point หลักคือถ้าเรา take strings สองตัวใดๆ เหล่านี้และ XOR เข้าด้วยกัน เราจะได้ string อีกตัวใน
code ดังนั้นมันเป็น linear code และ notation [7,4,3] ในวงเล็บเดี่ยวหมายความว่าบางอย่างที่คล้ายกับ double
square bracket notation ที่ฉันพูดถึงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้าสำหรับ stabilizer codes แต่ที่นี่เป็นสำหรับ classical linear
codes โดยเฉพาะ code words มีเจ็ด bits มี 16 code words ดังนั้นเราสามารถ encode สี่ bits โดยใช้ code และ
บังเอิญเป็น distance three code หมายความว่าคุณต้องพลิกอย่างน้อยสาม bits ของ code word ใดๆ เพื่อได้
code word ที่ต่างออกไป และนั่นหมายความว่ามันสามารถแก้สำหรับ bit flip error ได้ถึงหนึ่งตัว สิ่งเหล่านี้เป็นตัวอย่างง่ายๆ ของ
codes แต่แม้แต่ตัวอย่างของ [7,4,3] Hamming code ดูค่อนข้างลึกลับเมื่อเราแค่ list code words ทั้งหมด ดังนั้นเราต้องการวิธีที่ดีกว่าใน
การอธิบาย classical linear codes และมีสองวิธีธรรมชาติในการทำสิ่งนี้ วิธีหนึ่งคือ describe classical
linear codes โดยให้ minimal set ของ code words ที่ generate code หมายความว่าโดยการ take subsets ที่เป็นไปได้ทั้งหมด
ของ code words เหล่านี้และ XOR เข้าด้วยกัน เราได้ code ทั้งหมด และนั่นแสดงออกในรูปแบบคณิตศาสตร์
ที่นี่บนหน้าจอ อีกวิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเกี่ยวกับสิ่งนี้คือเรากำลังมอง code นี้เป็น subspace ของ vector space และ set
ของ generators เหล่านี้คือ basis สำหรับ subspace นั้น โดยจำไว้ว่านี่เป็น vector space ที่คำนวณ modulo 2 ถ้าเรามี M generators เรา
จะได้ code ที่มี 2 ยกกำลัง M elements แต่ละ generator เพิ่มจำนวน elements ใน code เป็นสองเท่า และ
สิ่งนั้นสอดคล้องกับ fact ที่ว่า classical linear codes บน binary alphabet มีจำนวน strings เสมอที่เป็น power ของ
two วิธีธรรมชาติที่สองในการอธิบาย classical linear code คือด้วย parity checks โดยเฉพาะ นี่คือ minimal
list ของ binary strings ที่มีความยาวเดียวกับ strings ใน code เช่นว่า strings ใน code คือเฉพาะอันที่ binary
dot product กับ parity check strings ทุกตัวเหล่านี้เป็นศูนย์ ที่ binary dot product ก็แค่ ordinary
inner product modulo 2 และอีกครั้งนั่นเป็นสิ่งที่เราพบในบทเรียนที่ห้าในบริบทของ query
algorithms และเหตุผลที่เรียก parity check strings ก็เพราะ string u ที่กำหนดมี binary product เท่ากับ
ศูนย์กับ v ก็ต่อเมื่อ bits ของ u ที่สอดคล้องกับ ones ใน v มี even
parity เมื่อเราอธิบาย classical linear code ในแบบนี้โดย minimal list ของ parity check strings แต่ละ parity
check string หาร number ของ strings ใน code ด้วยสอง ดังนั้นสำหรับ single code ที่อธิบายในสองแบบที่ต่างกันนี้ เราจะมีเสมอ m บวก r เท่ากับ
n สิ่งสำคัญอย่างหนึ่งที่ต้องสังเกตที่นี่คือ binary dot product ไม่ใช่ inner product ในแง่ formal และใน
โดยเฉพาะเมื่อ strings สองตัวมี binary dot product เท่ากับศูนย์ มันไม่ได้หมายความว่ามัน orthogonal ในแบบปกติที่เราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
orthogonality ตัวอย่างเช่น binary dot product ของ string 11 กับตัวเองคือศูนย์ ดังนั้นเป็นไปได้ที่
parity check strings อันใดอันหนึ่งเหล่านี้อยู่ใน code นั้นเอง ดังนั้นนั่นเป็นแค่บางอย่างที่ต้อง
จำ ตัวอย่างเช่น ตามที่เราทราบแล้ว 3-bit repetition code เป็น linear code ดังนั้นสามารถอธิบายได้ในทั้งสอง
แบบนี้ โดยเฉพาะมีแค่หนึ่งตัวเลือกสำหรับ generator ที่ทำงาน และนั่นคือ 111 และเราสามารถอธิบาย
code ได้อีกแบบด้วย parity check strings สองตัวนี้ ซึ่งควรดูคุ้นเคยจากการพูดถึงก่อนหน้าของเรา
code นี้ และสำหรับ [7,4,3] Hamming code เราสามารถใช้ generators เหล่านี้และ parity
checks เหล่านี้ และที่นี่โดยวิธี parity check strings ทั้งหมดของเราอยู่ใน code
ตัวเอง comment สุดท้ายเกี่ยวกับ classical linear codes แค่เพื่อเชื่อมพวกมันกับ stabilizer formalism parity check
strings เหล่านี้เทียบเท่ากับ stabilizer generators ที่เรามีแค่ Z และ identity Pauli matrices ตัวอย่างเช่น parity check
strings 110 และ 011 สำหรับ 3-bit repetition code สอดคล้องกับ stabilizer generators ZZI
และ IZZ อย่างแม่นยำ และสิ่งนั้นสอดคล้องกับการพูดถึง observables ชนิดนั้นจากบทเรียนก่อนหน้า
ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง CSS codes ซึ่งเป็น stabilizer codes ที่สามารถได้มาโดยการรวม certain
คู่ของ classical linear codes ที่มี bits เดียวกันในการ encode เข้าด้วยกัน สิ่งนี้ไม่ทำงานสำหรับ classical linear codes สองตัวใดๆ
codes สองตัวต้องมีความสัมพันธ์บางอย่างตามที่เราจะเห็นในไม่ช้า แต่อย่างไรก็ตาม
construction นี้เปิดความเป็นไปได้มากมายสำหรับ quantum error correcting codes ที่อาศัยส่วนหนึ่งจากสิ่งที่เราเรียนรู้จากกว่า 75 ปีของ
classical coding theory ฉันพูดถึงแล้วว่าใน stabilizer formalism stabilizer
generators ที่มีเฉพาะ Z และ identity Pauli matrices เทียบเท่ากับ parity checks ตัวอย่างเช่นใน 3-bit
repetition code เราสามารถใช้ parity check strings 110 และ 011 ซึ่งบังคับว่า leftmost สอง bits เป็น
equal และ rightmost สอง bits เป็น equal สำหรับทุก string ใน code และ parity check strings สองตัวนี้สอดคล้องกับ stabilizer
generators ZZI และ IZZ อย่างแม่นยำ สำหรับ [7,4,3] Hamming code เราสามารถใช้
parity check strings เหล่านี้ และมันสอดคล้องกับ stabilizer generators เหล่านี้ ที่เราแค่แทน one แต่ละตัวด้วย Z และ zero แต่ละตัวด้วย identity
คุณอาจจำ stabilizer generators เหล่านี้ได้โดยวิธีเพราะสิ่งเหล่านี้คือสามในหกของ stabilizer generators สำหรับ 7-qubit Steane code นั่น
ไม่ใช่เรื่องบังเอิญอย่างแน่นอน และเราจะเห็นอย่างแน่ชัดว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นที่นี่ในไม่ช้า เราจะตั้งชื่อ Z
stabilizer generators ให้กับ stabilizer generators แบบนี้ หมายความว่ามีเฉพาะ Pauli Z และ identity tensor
factors ดังนั้น X และ Y ไม่เคยปรากฏใน Z stabilizer generator เรายังสามารถพิจารณา
stabilizer generators ที่มีเฉพาะ X และ identity Pauli matrices ปรากฏ และเราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ stabilizer generators แบบนี้ว่าเทียบเท่าอย่างสมบูรณ์
กับ Z stabilizer generators ยกเว้นว่าโดยพื้นฐานอธิบาย parity checks ใน plus minus basis แทน standard
basis ตัวอย่างเช่น กลับไปที่ [7,4,3] Hamming code เราสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ
stabilizer generators ที่เหลืออีกสามตัวจาก 7-qubit Steane code ซึ่งบังเอิญตาม pattern เดียวกับสำหรับ Z stabilizer generators สำหรับ
code นี้พอดี แต่ครั้งนี้เราแทน X แทนหนึ่งแทนที่จะเป็น Z และสิ่งที่เราได้จากแค่สาม stabilizer generators เหล่านี้
คือ code ที่มี states 16 ตัวที่แสดงที่นี่ ซึ่งเราได้โดยการ apply Hadamard gates กับ standard
basis states ที่สอดคล้องกับ strings ใน [7,4,3] Hamming code และแน่นอน code space ของเรายังมี
linear combinations ของ states เหล่านี้ ตามธรรมชาติ stabilizer generators ชนิดนี้เรียกว่า X stabilizer generators
ดังนั้นไม่มี Y หรือ Z ที่นี่ และตอนนี้เราสามารถ define CSS codes ใน
รูปแบบง่ายๆ CSS codes คือ stabilizer codes ที่สามารถแสดงโดยใช้เฉพาะ Z
stabilizer generators และ X stabilizer generators ดังนั้นไม่มี Y ที่อนุญาต และไม่มี X และ Z ปรากฏใน stabilizer
generator เดียวกัน และเพื่อให้แน่ใจว่าสิ่งนี้ชัดเจน เราควรจำไว้ว่ามีอิสระในวิธีที่เราเลือก stabilizer generators สำหรับ stabilizer
codes และสิ่งที่ definition นี้บอกคือ CSS code คืออันที่เป็นไปได้ที่จะเลือกแค่ Z และ X
stabilizer generators แต่โดยทั่วไปคุณสามารถเลือก stabilizer generators ที่ต่างกันที่อาจไม่ใช่ Z หรือ X stabilizer generators ถ้าต้องการ
นี่คือตัวอย่างที่ไม่ trivial ที่ง่ายที่สุดเกือบๆ ของ CSS code ที่เราสามารถมีได้ ที่มีทั้ง Z stabilizer
generator และ X stabilizer generator และการตรวจสอบนั้นต้องการไม่มากกว่าการมอง เนื่องจากเราทราบจาก
บทเรียนก่อนหน้าว่านี่เป็น valid stabilizer code code space เป็น one-dimensional มันคือ space span โดย
phi plus Bell state และเราสังเกตได้ว่า stabilizer generators สองตัวของเรากระทำ trivially บน vector นี้โดยการพิจารณา
expressions สองแบบของ ebit ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ พร้อมกับการตีความของ stabilizer generators เป็น parity checks ใน 0/1
และ plus/minus bases 7-qubit Steane code เป็นอีกตัวอย่างของ CSS code เพราะสำหรับ
การเลือก generators นี้ เรามีเฉพาะ Z และ X stabilizer generators และอีกครั้งเราทราบแล้วว่านี่เป็น valid
stabilizer code และ 9-qubit Shore code ก็เป็นอีกตัวอย่าง ครั้งนี้เรามีหก Z
stabilizer generators และแค่สอง X stabilizer generators และไม่เป็นไร ไม่จำเป็นต้องมีความสมดุลหรือ
symmetry ระหว่างสองชนิด อย่างไรก็ตามมันสำคัญมากที่เราต้องมี valid stabilizer code จริงๆ และนั่นหมายความว่า
แต่ละ Z stabilizer generators ต้องสับเปลี่ยนกับแต่ละ X stabilizer generators ดังนั้นคุณไม่สามารถ
เลือก generators สองชนิดได้อย่างอิสระ และฉันจะพูดเพิ่มเติมอีกนิดเกี่ยวกับเรื่องนี้ในภายหลังในบทเรียน ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง error
detection และ correction สำหรับ CSS codes และสิ่งที่เราจะพบคือ property ที่เราสังเกตสำหรับ 9-qubit Shore
code ที่เราสามารถ detect และ correct X errors และ Z errors ได้อย่างอิสระ ใช้ได้ทั่วไปสำหรับ CSS codes
เพื่ออธิบายสิ่งนี้เพิ่มเติม พิจารณา CSS code เช่น 7-qubit Steane code แต่อาจเป็น CSS code ที่ต่างออกไปถ้า
ต้องการ แนวคิดพื้นฐานคือ Z stabilizer generators detect X errors
แต่มันไม่รับรู้ Z errors เลยเพราะ Z stabilizer generators สับเปลี่ยนกับ Z
errors เสมอ นอกจากนี้ Z stabilizer generators ยังสับเปลี่ยนกับ Z gates ใดก็ตามที่เราอาจเลือก apply เป็น
corrections สำหรับ Z errors ในทำนองเดียวกัน X stabilizer generators detect Z errors แต่มันไม่รับรู้
X errors และ corrections เลย ดังนั้นเราสามารถโดยพื้นฐานคิดเกี่ยวกับ Z stabilizer generators ว่าแทน
classical linear code ที่ป้องกัน bit flips หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง X errors ในขณะที่ X stabilizer generators
แทน classical linear code ใน plus minus basis ที่อย่างอิสระสมบูรณ์ป้องกัน flips
ระหว่าง plus และ minus states หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง phase flip errors หรือ Z errors ดังนั้นตอนนี้ค่อนข้างชัดเจนว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
กับ Steane code มันแค่เป็น [7,4,3] Hamming code สำหรับ bit flip errors และ [7,4,3] Hamming code สำหรับ phase flip
errors อีกครั้ง fact ที่ว่า Z stabilizer generators และ X stabilizer generators สับเปลี่ยนกันเป็นสิ่งจำเป็น
มันจะไม่เป็น valid stabilizer code ถ้าพวกมันไม่สับเปลี่ยน และคุณอาจบอกว่าเป็นโชคดีที่ [7,4,3] Hamming code
ทำงานออกมาแบบนี้ แต่มีตัวเลือกอื่นๆ อีกมากมายที่สามารถทำสำหรับคู่ของ classical linear codes ที่จะให้ valid stabilizer code เมื่อ
รวมในแบบนี้ ตอนนี้กลับไปที่ CSS codes โดยทั่วไป สมมติว่า Z stabilizer
generators อนุญาตให้ correct ได้ถึง J X errors และ X stabilizer generators อนุญาตให้ correct ได้
ถึง K Z errors ดังนั้นในกรณีของ Steane code J และ K เป็นหนึ่งทั้งคู่เพราะ
[7,4,3] Hamming code สามารถแก้ bit flip หนึ่งตัว แต่โดยทั่วไปตัวเลข J และ K เหล่านี้อาจต่างกัน
จากนั้นตามมาโดย discretization ของ errors ที่ CSS code สามารถแก้ errors ใดๆ บน qubits จำนวน
ไม่เกิน minimum ของ J และ K นั่นเพราะเมื่อเรา measure syndrome arbitrary error บน
qubits บางจำนวน effectively collapses probabilistically เป็น combination บางอย่างของ X errors, Z errors หรือทั้งคู่ จากนั้น
X errors และ Z errors สามารถ detect และ correct ได้อย่างอิสระ ดังนั้นตราบเท่าที่เรามีสอง
classical linear codes ที่เข้ากันได้ในแง่ที่ให้ X และ Z stabilizer generators ที่สับเปลี่ยนกัน
CSS code ที่เราได้จากการรวมพวกมันโดยพื้นฐานรับ error correction properties ของ codes สองตัวในแง่ที่ฉัน
อธิบายไป สังเกตว่ามีราคาที่ต้องจ่าย ซึ่งก็คือเราไม่สามารถ encode qubits ได้มากเท่ากับที่เราทำได้กับ bits
กับ classical codes สองตัว เพราะจำนวน stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดสำหรับ CSS code คือผลรวมของ
จำนวน parity checks สำหรับ classical codes สองตัว และแต่ละ stabilizer generator ลด dimension ของ code space
ลงครึ่งหนึ่ง ตัวอย่างเช่น [7,4,3] Hamming code อนุญาตให้ encode classical bits สี่ตัวเพราะเรามีแค่
parity checks สามตัวสำหรับ code นี้ ในขณะที่ 7-qubit Steane code encode เพียงหนึ่ง qubit เพราะมี
stabilizer generators หกตัว สิ่งสุดท้ายที่ฉันจะอธิบายเกี่ยวกับ CSS codes โดยทั่วไปในบทเรียนนี้เกี่ยวข้องกับ code spaces ของ CSS codes
และหน้าตาเป็นอย่างไร และนี่จะให้โอกาสเราตรวจสอบในรายละเอียดเพิ่มเติมเล็กน้อยเกี่ยวกับความสัมพันธ์ที่ต้องมีระหว่าง
classical linear codes สองตัวเพื่อให้ compatible ในแง่ที่เราสามารถรวมเข้าด้วยกันเพื่อสร้าง CSS
code พิจารณา CSS code arbitrary บน N qubits และให้ Z1 ถึง Zs เป็น n-bit
parity check strings ที่สอดคล้องกับ Z stabilizer generators ซึ่งหมายความว่า classical
linear code ที่อธิบายด้วย Z stabilizer generators ซึ่งเราจะเรียกว่า CZ แค่เพื่อช่วยให้เราจำว่า
นี่คือ code ที่สอดคล้องกับ Z stabilizer generators อยู่ในรูปแบบที่แสดงที่นี่บนหน้าจอ ใน words code มีทุก
string u ที่ binary dot product กับแต่ละ parity check strings เป็นศูนย์ ถ้าต้องการเราสามารถยัง
พิจารณา different code ที่ derived จาก strings เดียวกันเหล่านี้ ซึ่งเราจะเรียกว่า DZ และแนวคิดที่นี่คือเราคิดเกี่ยวกับ
strings Z1 ถึง Zs เหล่านี้ไม่ใช่เป็น parity check strings แต่เป็น generators
ณ จุดนี้ยังไม่ชัดเจนว่าทำไมเราถึงต้องการคิดเกี่ยวกับ code นี้ แต่เราสามารถทำได้ และมันจะกลายเป็นเกี่ยวข้องกับ
การพูดถึงนี้ code นี้เรียกว่า dual code ของ CZ และมักเรียกว่า CZ perp หมายถึง CZ ที่มี perpendicular
symbol เป็น superscript แต่เราจะเรียกว่า DZ และจะจำได้ง่ายพอเพราะ D ย่อมาจาก
dual เราสามารถทำสิ่งที่คล้ายกันกับ X stabilizer generators ด้วย ดังนั้นครั้งนี้ CX คือ classical linear code
ที่ parity check strings สอดคล้องกับ X stabilizer generators และ DX คือ dual code ของ code นี้ เป็นการกล่าวแย้ง
เราสามารถอธิบาย conditions ที่ต้องมีเพื่อให้ CZ และ CX compatible ในแง่ที่เราสามารถ
จับคู่พวกมันเป็น CSS code ในรูปของ codes เหล่านี้เอง โดยเฉพาะต้องเป็นว่า
DZ อยู่ใน CX หรือเทียบเท่าที่ DX อยู่ใน CZ และตอนนี้
เป็นไปได้ที่จะอธิบาย code space ของ CSS code ที่ derived จาก codes สองตัวนี้ และวิธีหนึ่งในการอธิบายคือ
มันคือ space span โดย vectors ทั้งหมดที่อยู่ในรูปแบบที่แสดงบนหน้าจอ ใน words มันดูเหมือน uniform
superpositions บน strings ใน dual code DX ของ code ที่สอดคล้องกับ X stabilizer generators ที่ shift
โดยหรือ XOR กับ strings ใน code CZ ที่สอดคล้องกับ Z stabilizer generators และเราจะเห็นว่ามันดู
อย่างไรในกรณีเฉพาะของ Steane code ในอีกสักครู่ สิ่งนี้ make sense เพราะ states ใน code space ต้องเป็น
plus one eigenvectors ของ stabilizer generators ทั้งหมด และโดยเฉพาะการคูณด้วย X
stabilizer generators อันใดอันหนึ่งเทียบเท่ากับการ XOR กับ X string ที่สอดคล้องกัน ดังนั้นนั่นเป็นเหตุผลที่ uniform superpositions
บน DX ที่ shift ด้วย strings ต่างๆ ปรากฏแบบนี้ การเลือกต่างกันสำหรับ shift
ที่แสดงโดย string Y ใน expression นี้อาจให้ vector เดียวกันได้โดยวิธี ดังนั้น states เหล่านี้ไม่ได้ distinct ทั้งหมด แต่รวมกันพวกมัน span
code space ทั้งหมด มี symmetry ที่นี่ระหว่าง X และ Z stabilizer generators และ
codes ที่สอดคล้องกัน และดังนั้นเราสามารถใช้ symmetry นั้นในการอธิบาย vectors ใน code space ในแบบที่คล้ายกันโดย swap X และ Z แต่
เราต้อง swap standard bases สำหรับ plus minus bases ด้วย ซึ่งเป็นเหตุผลที่ Hadamard operations ปรากฏใน
expression นี้ ตอนนี้สำหรับตัวอย่างที่สัญญาไว้ซึ่งก็คือ Steane code เราจบลงด้วย encoding ที่เป็นไปได้สองตัวเหล่านี้สำหรับ
zero และ one standard basis states โดยเฉพาะเราสามารถ encode zero state เป็น uniform
superposition บน eight strings ใน dual code ของ [7,4,3] Hamming code ซึ่งกลายเป็นครึ่งหนึ่งของ strings ใน [7,4,3] Hamming code และเรา
สามารถ encode one state ในแบบที่คล้ายกัน ยกเว้นว่า strings ทั้งหมดถูก XOR กับ all-one string ในกรณีนี้
เพราะ string นั้นอยู่ใน [7,4,3] Hamming code แต่ไม่ใช่ใน dual ของมัน comment สุดท้ายที่นี่คือเรามักไม่
สนใจเกี่ยวกับหน้าตาของ vectors ใน code spaces ของเรามากนักเพราะโดยทั่วไปเราไม่จำเป็นต้องรู้สิ่งนี้เพื่อใช้
codes ดังนั้นถ้าคำอธิบายนี้ไม่ชัดเจนมันไม่ใช่บางอย่างที่ต้องกังวลมากนัก แต่มัน
ธรรมชาติที่จะถามว่า vectors ใน code spaces ของ CSS codes หน้าตาเป็นอย่างไร และ description นี้ให้คำตอบสำหรับ
คำถามนั้น ต่อไปเราจะพูดถึง CSS code เฉพาะที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ toric code ซึ่งเป็นตัวอย่างของบางสิ่งที่รู้จักกันในชื่อ
topological quantum error correcting code code นี้ถูกค้นพบโดย Alexei Kitaev ใน
ปี 1997 จริงๆ แล้ว toric code ไม่ใช่ single code แต่เป็น family ของ codes หนึ่งสำหรับแต่ละ positive integer
ที่อย่างน้อยสอง codes เหล่านี้มี key properties บางอย่าง key property แรกคือ
stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดมี low weight เป็น Pauli operations โดยเฉพาะมันจะมี
weight สี่ทั้งหมด และนี่ดีเพราะหมายความว่าแต่ละ stabilizer generator measurement ไม่ต้องการ
qubits มากเกินไป บางครั้งผู้คนพูดถึง quantum LDPC codes หรือ quantum low density parity
check codes และนี่คือสิ่งที่หมายถึงด้วยคำนี้ ที่ low ในกรณีนี้หมายถึงสี่ ดังนั้น toric code เป็นตัวอย่างของ
quantum LDPC code toric code ยังมีสิ่งที่เรียกว่า geometric locality ซึ่งหมายความว่าไม่เพียง
stabilizer generators มี low weight แต่ยังเป็นไปได้ที่จะจัด qubits ใน spatial เพื่อให้
แต่ละ stabilizer generator measurement เกี่ยวข้องเฉพาะ qubits ที่อยู่ใกล้กัน ซึ่งทำให้การ measurements เหล่านี้ง่ายกว่าในการ implement ใน
ทางทฤษฎี และสุดท้าย codes เหล่านี้มี large distance ดังนั้นพวกมันสามารถทนต่อ error rate ที่ค่อนข้างสูง
นี่คือวิธีที่ codes เหล่านี้ทำงาน ก่อนอื่นให้ L เป็น positive
integer ที่อย่างน้อยสอง และพิจารณา L คูณ L lattice ที่มี periodic
boundaries ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือ L คูณ L lattice สำหรับ L เท่ากับ 8 และสังเกตว่า lines
ทางขวาและด้านล่างเป็น dotted lines และแนวคิดที่นี่คือเราต้องการคิดเกี่ยวกับ dotted line ทางขวาว่าเป็น line เดียวกับ
line ทางซ้าย และในทำนองเดียวกัน dotted line ด้านล่างก็เป็น line เดียวกับ
ด้านบน ดังนั้นถ้าเราต้องการ realize configuration ชนิดนี้จริงๆ ทางกายภาพ เราต้องการสาม
มิติ โดยเฉพาะเราสามารถสร้าง cylinder โดยก่อนจับคู่ด้านซ้ายและขวา แล้ว bend
cylinder เพื่อให้ circles ที่ ends ซึ่งเคยเป็น top และ bottom edges ของ lattice มาพบกัน หรือ
จะจับคู่ top และ bottom ก่อนแล้วค่อย sides มันทำงานได้ทั้งสองแบบ และไม่สำคัญว่าจะทำแบบไหนสำหรับ
การพูดถึงนี้ สิ่งที่เราได้คือ torus หรืออีกนัยหนึ่งคือโดนัท แม้ว่าการคิดเกี่ยวกับมันเป็น inner tube ของยาง
อาจเป็นภาพที่ดีกว่าในใจ เพราะนี่ไม่ใช่ solid lattice ได้กลายเป็นแค่ surface ของ
torus และนี่คือที่มาของชื่อ toric code วิธีที่คุณสามารถเคลื่อนที่ไปรอบๆ
torus แบบนี้ สมมติว่าคุณสามารถเคลื่อนที่ระหว่าง adjacent points บน lattice น่าจะคุ้นเคยกับผู้ที่เคยเล่น old school video
games ที่ถ้าคุณเคลื่อนที่ออกจาก top edge ของหน้าจอคุณโผล่ขึ้นมาที่ bottom และเช่นเดียวกันสำหรับ left และ right edges ของ
หน้าจอ และส่วนใหญ่นี่คือวิธีที่ฉันจะอธิบาย lattice นี้แทนที่จะพูดเฉพาะเกี่ยวกับ
torus ใน three-dimensional space ต่อไปเราจินตนาการว่า qubits
ถูกวางบน edges ของ lattice ตามที่แสดงที่นี่บนหน้าจอ ที่ qubits ถูกชี้ด้วย solid blue
circles สังเกตโดยวิธีว่า qubits ที่วางบน dotted lines ไม่ solid และนั่นเพราะเราได้แสดง qubits เหล่านั้น
แล้วด้วยอันตาม top หรือ left hand side โดยจำว่า lines ด้านบนและซ้ายเป็น lines เดียวกับ
อันที่ชี้โดย dotted lines ด้านล่างและขวา ดังนั้นถ้าเรานับ qubits ทั้งหมดเหล่านี้ เราได้ 2 คูณ L กำลังสอง qubits และวิธีหนึ่ง
ในการเห็นนั้นคือสังเกตว่าเราได้ L กำลังสอง qubits บน horizontal edges และ L กำลังสอง qubits บน vertical
edges ดังนั้นนั่นคือ layout ของ qubits ของเรา และเพื่ออธิบาย toric code เองเราแค่ต้องอธิบาย stabilizer
generators และมีสองชนิด ก่อนอื่นเรามี Z stabilizer generators
และสิ่งเหล่านี้สอดคล้องกับ tiles หรือ plaquettes ในรูป และประการที่สองเรามี X stabilizer
generators และสิ่งเหล่านี้สอดคล้องกับ vertices ในรูป ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือ
stabilizer generator ตัวหนึ่ง ซึ่งหมายความว่าเรากำลัง tensor Pauli Z operation หนึ่งตัวสำหรับแต่ละ qubits ที่สัมผัส tile นี้ พร้อมกับ identity matrices
บน qubits อื่นๆ ทั้งหมด และนั่นให้เรา Pauli operation ที่มี weight สี่ และนี่คือตัวอย่างของ X
stabilizer generator ที่เรามี Pauli X matrices กระทำบน four qubits ที่ incident กับ vertex นี้ พร้อมกับ
identity matrices บน qubits อื่นๆ ทั้งหมด ดังนั้นอีกครั้งมันเป็น Pauli operation ที่มี weight สี่ มันสำคัญว่าสำหรับทั้งสอง
ชนิดของ stabilizer generators เหล่านี้ เราต้องรวมอันที่ wrap around ที่ periodic boundaries และนี่คือตัวอย่างของ X stabilizer generator
ที่ทำสิ่งนี้ ตอนนี้เพื่อให้ได้ valid stabilizer code เราต้องการ stabilizer
generators ที่สับเปลี่ยนกัน Z stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดสับเปลี่ยนกันเองเพราะ Z สับเปลี่ยนกับตัวมันเองและ identity
สับเปลี่ยนกับทุกอย่าง และในทำนองเดียวกันสำหรับ X stabilizer generators มันยังชัดเจนว่า Z stabilizer generator และ X
stabilizer generator สับเปลี่ยนกันเมื่อกระทำ non-trivially บน disjoint sets ของ qubits เหมือน generators สองตัวที่แสดง
ที่นี่ ความเป็นไปได้ที่เหลือคือ Z stabilizer generator และ X stabilizer generator overlap และ
เมื่อใดก็ตามที่เกิดขึ้น มันเป็นสอง qubits เสมอที่พวกมัน overlap และดังนั้น stabilizer generators สับเปลี่ยนกันเพราะ ZZ
และ XX สับเปลี่ยนกัน ตอนนี้นี่ไม่ใช่ minimal set ของ stabilizer generators โดยเฉพาะถ้าเรา multiply
Z stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดเข้าด้วยกัน เราได้ identity เพราะทุก qubit ถูกคูณด้วย Z สองครั้ง
ครั้งหนึ่งสำหรับแต่ละ tile ที่สัมผัส qubit นั่นหมายความว่าการ multiply Z stabilizer generators ทั้งหมด
ยกเว้นหนึ่งตัวเข้าด้วยกันให้ last one แก่เรา ดังนั้นพวกมันไม่ independent แต่ถ้าเราลบหนึ่งตัวออกเราจะได้
independent set และเช่นเดียวกันสำหรับ X stabilizer generators ดังนั้นเราสามารถลบหนึ่งตัวของแต่ละชนิดออก
และไม่สำคัญว่าจะลบตัวไหน และนั่นเหลือ L กำลังสอง ลบ 1 stabilizer generators ของแต่ละชนิด เพื่อ
ความชัดเจนเรื่องนี้ และนี่คือสิ่งที่ฉันพาดพิงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า เราสนใจจริงๆ กับ stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดเหล่านี้ และใน
แง่ operational เคร่งครัด เราจะไม่เลือกหนึ่งตัวของแต่ละชนิดเพื่อ ignore แต่เพื่อการวิเคราะห์ code เราสามารถ
จินตนาการว่า stabilizer generator หนึ่งตัวของแต่ละชนิดถูกลบออกเพื่อให้ได้ minimal generating set โดยจำ
ว่าเราสามารถ infer ผลของ generators ที่ลบออกเหล่านี้เสมอ โดยมองว่าเป็น observables จากผลของ stabilizer
generator observables อื่นๆ ทั้งหมดของชนิดเดียวกัน ดังนั้นจำนวน qubits ที่ code นี้ encode เท่ากับจำนวน
qubits ทั้งหมดคือ 2 คูณ L กำลังสอง ลบ จำนวน stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดใน minimal generating set คือ 2 คูณ L กำลังสอง ลบ
2 และนั่นหมายความว่าเราสามารถ encode 2 qubits ฉันไม่ได้ argue โดยวิธีว่า code space ไม่ trivial แต่มันไม่
trivial จริงๆ และฉันจะปล่อยให้คุณโน้มน้าวตัวเองว่าไม่มีทางที่จะ multiply stabilizer generators เข้าด้วยกันในแบบที่ให้เรา
ลบ 1 คูณ identity ดังนั้นนั่นคือ toric code เองและ ณ จุดนี้อาจยังไม่
ชัดเจนเลยว่าทำไม code นี้จึงดีสำหรับ quantum error correction มันยังเหลือสำหรับเราที่จะวิเคราะห์มัน และสิ่งที่เราจะพบคือมัน
จริงๆ เป็น quantum error correcting code ที่น่าทึ่งมาก เพื่อเข้าใจวิธีที่ toric code ทำหน้าที่เป็น quantum error correcting
code เราจะเริ่มด้วยการพิจารณา errors ต่างๆ และ syndromes ที่พวกมัน generate สิ่งแรกที่ต้องสังเกตคือ
toric code เป็น CSS code เพราะ stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดของเราเป็นทั้ง Z หรือ X stabilizer
generators และสิ่งที่หมายความว่าคือ X errors และ Z errors สามารถ detect และอาจ correct ได้
แยกกัน และจริงๆ มี simple symmetry ระหว่าง Z และ X stabilizer generators ที่ช่วยให้เราวิเคราะห์ X
errors และ Z errors ในแบบเดียวกันโดยพื้นฐาน ดังนั้นฉันจะโฟกัสที่ X errors ซึ่งอาจ detect ได้โดย Z
stabilizer generators และคุณสามารถแปล Z errors ทุกอย่างซึ่งอาจ detect ได้โดย X stabilizer generators โดยใช้
แนวคิดเดียวกันพอดี นี่คือรูปที่แสดง qubits สองกำลังสองของเราบน edges ของ L
คูณ L lattice ที่มี periodic boundaries และเราสามารถจินตนาการว่านี่วางอยู่บน surface ของ
torus ในตอนนี้ qubits ทั้งหมดเป็นสีน้ำเงิน ชี้ว่าสิ่งเหล่านี้คือ qubits ที่ไม่ได้รับผลกระทบจาก
errors ดังนั้นคุณควรจินตนาการว่า ณ จุดนี้ state ของ qubits เหล่านี้อยู่ใน code space สำหรับ
code นี้ ตามที่ฉันพูดถึง focus ของเราจะอยู่ที่ X errors และในอีกครู่เราจะใช้ magenta circles เพื่อชี้ qubits ที่
ได้รับผลกระทบจาก X errors X errors detect ได้โดย Z stabilizer generators ซึ่งสอดคล้องกับ
tiles ในรูป ดังนั้นสิ่งที่เราสามารถทำได้คือให้ white tiles ชี้ plus one measurement outcomes หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง
entries ใน syndrome ที่สอดคล้องกับ generator นั้น ในขณะที่ gray tiles จะชี้ minus one measurement
outcomes คุณสามารถคิดเกี่ยวกับ plus one outcome หรืออีกนัยหนึ่ง white tile ว่าชี้ว่า
stabilizer generator ที่สอดคล้อง happy ทุกอย่างดูโอเคสำหรับ generator นี้ ส่วน minus one outcome หรือ gray tile
ชี้ว่า stabilizer generator ที่สอดคล้อง unhappy เพราะเห็นได้ชัดว่า error ต้องเกิดขึ้นเพื่อก่อให้เกิด
outcome นี้ ดังนั้น ณ ตอนนี้ stabilizer generators ทั้งหมดของเรา happy เพราะไม่มี errors เกิดขึ้น ตอนนี้ถ้าเราคิด
เกี่ยวกับ Z stabilizer generator มันกำลัง measure parity ของ 4 qubits ที่สัมผัส tile ด้วย
standard basis เท่านั้น ดังนั้น plus one outcome ไม่ได้ชี้ว่าไม่มี X errors เกิดขึ้นบน four
qubits เหล่านี้ แต่ชี้ว่า even number ของ X errors เกิดขึ้น ในขณะที่ minus one outcome ชี้ว่า
odd number ของ X errors เกิดขึ้น ดังนั้นตอนนี้ introduce X error และดูว่า
เกิดอะไรขึ้น Z stabilizer generators สองตัวที่สอดคล้องกับ tiles ที่สัมผัส qubit นี้ unhappy ในตอนนี้เพราะ
X error นี้ anti-commute กับ generators ทั้งสองเหล่านี้ หรือเทียบเท่าในรูปของ standard basis ตอนนี้เราอยู่ใน
state ที่ทั้งสอง sets ของ four qubits ที่สอดคล้องกับ tiles สองตัวมี odd parity ดังนั้นนั่นคือผลของ single
X error ดังนั้นถ้าเรา measure syndrome นี้และเรารู้หรือสมมติว่ามีแค่ X error เดียว เราจะ
สามารถ infer ได้ง่ายๆ ว่า qubit ไหน flip และเราสามารถ flip มันกลับด้วย X gate ตอนนี้ดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
เมื่อเรา introduce X errors เพิ่มเติม และโดยเฉพาะดูว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นเมื่อ X error ที่สองเกิดขึ้นบน
qubit อีกตัวที่สัมผัส gray tile ตัวใดตัวหนึ่ง สมมติว่า gray tile ด้านบน เช่น
นี้ tile นั้น happy ในตอนนี้เพราะ X errors สองตัวเกิดขึ้นบน qubits ที่สัมผัส tile นี้ และสองเป็น even ดังนั้น
X errors สองตัวเหล่านี้ด้วยกัน commute กับ stabilizer generator สำหรับ tile นี้ อีกวิธีพูดคือ
X error ที่สองนี้ shift standard basis states ทั้งหมดสำหรับ four qubits เหล่านี้จาก odd parity กลับไป even
parity tile ทางซ้ายของ X error ใหม่นี้ในทางกลับกัน unhappy ในตอนนี้
เราสามารถดำเนินกระบวนการของการเพิ่ม X errors ใหม่ต่อไป และตราบเท่าที่เราสร้าง chain ของ adjacent X errors ที่ adjacent หมายความว่า qubits สัมผัส
tile เดียวกัน เราจะ effectively push minus 1 measurement outcome นั้นไปรอบๆ และสิ่งที่เราพบคือเรามีเสมอ
minus one syndrome measurement outcomes ที่ end points ของ chains ของ adjacent errors ดังนั้นเราสามารถ detect chains ของ
adjacent X errors เสมอตราบเท่าที่มัน end points มีโดยวิธีอาจมี chains หลายอัน แต่เราจะกลับมา
สู่ความเป็นไปได้นั้นในภายหลัง อย่างไรก็ตามเป็นไปได้ที่เราสามารถมี chain ของ adjacent X errors ที่
ไม่มี end points ซึ่งหมายความว่า chain ของ errors ของเราอาจสร้าง closed loop ดังนั้นเพิ่ม errors บางส่วนเพื่อ
ให้สร้าง closed loop เช่น นี้ ตอนนี้เรามี even number ของ X
errors บนทุก tile ดังนั้น stabilizer generator ทุกตัว happy ในตอนนี้ และสิ่งที่เราพบคือ closed
loops ของ adjacent X errors ไม่ detect ได้โดย code นี้ เพราะเราได้ all plus 1 syndrome ใน
กรณีดังกล่าว ดังนั้นอาจดูน่าผิดหวัง จริงๆ แล้วเราต้องการแค่ four adjacent X errors เพื่อสร้าง closed loop
และเราหวังว่าจะได้อะไรดีกว่า distance 4 code อย่างไรก็ตาม closed loops บางตัวของ
adjacent X errors อยู่ใน stabilizer เองแล้ว จำว่าเรามี X stabilizer generator สำหรับแต่ละ vertex ใน
lattice และถ้าเรา multiply X stabilizer generators ที่ adjacent เข้าด้วยกัน เราสามารถสร้าง closed loops ของ X
operations เช่น ที่เรามีที่นี่สำหรับ closed loop ที่เราสร้างเมื่อสักครู่ ดังนั้น closed loops บางตัวของ X errors
เช่น อันที่แสดงที่นี่จริงๆ ไม่ใช่ errors เลยเพราะมันอยู่ใน stabilizer ดังนั้นมันไม่ทำอะไรเลยกับ code space มีอย่างไรก็ตาม
closed loops บางตัวของ X errors ที่ไม่ใช่ใน stabilizer และดังนั้นพวกมันแสดง non-trivial errors ที่ไป
ไม่ detect โดย code และมีวิธีค่อนข้างง่ายในการ characterize ชนิดต่างๆ ของ
loops loops ที่ข้าม every line ใน lattice หมายความว่า every vertical line จากบนลงล่างและ every horizontal line
จากซ้ายไปขวา even number ของครั้งเสมอเป็น products ของ X stabilizer generators ซึ่งรวมถึงตัวอย่าง
ที่แสดงบนหน้าจอรวมถึง loops ที่อาจซับซ้อนกว่ามากรวมถึงความเป็นไปได้ที่มัน cross periodic boundaries แต่
อย่างไรก็ตามโดยการ multiply closed loops ของ X errors เหล่านี้ด้วย X stabilizer generators พวกมันสามารถ effectively ถูก shrink ลงไปเป็น
nothing และมัน certainly จริงโดยวิธีว่าเราสามารถได้ loops แบบนี้เท่านั้นโดยการ multiply X stabilizer generators เข้าด้วยกัน เพราะ every X stabilizer
generator ใส่ even number ของ X operations บน every horizontal line และบน every vertical
line ชนิดอื่นของ closed loop ที่เราสามารถมีคืออันที่ข้ามอย่างน้อยหนึ่ง line odd number ของครั้ง เช่น
อันที่แสดงที่นี่ซึ่งข้าม every horizontal line แค่ครั้งเดียว และนี่คืออีกตัวอย่างที่ข้าม
each vertical line แค่ครั้งเดียว ดังนั้นสิ่งเหล่านี้เป็นตัวอย่างของ non-trivial errors ที่ไปไม่ detect โดย code แต่ key
ที่นี่คือวิธีเดียวในการสร้าง closed loop แบบนี้คือการไปรอบๆ torus ไม่ว่าจะ around รูใน
กลางของ torus หรือ through รู หรืออาจทั้งสอง นี่เป็น topological property
เกี่ยวกับ torus มันเกี่ยวกับรูทั้งหมดโดยพื้นฐาน และนั่นเป็นเหตุผลที่นี่เรียกว่า topological quantum error correcting
code ในรูปแบบ visualization นี้ของ two-dimensional lattice ที่มี periodic boundaries chain ในหมวดหมู่นี้ต้อง
loop around หนึ่งหรือทั้งสอง periodic boundaries ในแบบที่ทำให้เป็นไปไม่ได้ที่จะ contract loop นั้นเป็น
point โดยการ multiply ด้วย X stabilizer generators chain ดังกล่าวอาจ
ซับซ้อนกว่าอันที่แสดงที่นี่ แต่นี่คือที่สั้นที่สุดที่ loop ดังกล่าวสามารถเป็นได้ เพราะมันต้อง loop รอบๆ
หนึ่งหรือทั้งสอง periodic boundaries และสิ่งที่นี่หมายความว่าคือ minimum weight ของ non-trivial
undetectable error คือ L closed loop ใดๆ ที่มี errors น้อยกว่านั้นต้องอยู่ใน first category และดังนั้น
อยู่ใน stabilizer และ chains ของ errors ที่ไม่สร้าง closed loops detect ได้โดย code และนั่นแหละ นั่นคือเหตุผลที่ code
นี้ทำงาน และสิ่งที่เราจบลงได้คือ [[2L squared, 2, L]] stabilizer code เราใช้ 2 L กำลังสอง
qubits เพื่อ encode 2 qubits และ code มี distance L ต่อไปฉันจะพูดสักนิดเกี่ยวกับ
การ correct errors ด้วย toric code แม้ว่าจะไม่ลงรายละเอียดมากนัก ถ้าเรา measure syndrome และ
เราเห็นบางอย่างนอกจาก all plus 1 syndrome ที่นี่ฉันกำลังพูดเกี่ยวกับแค่ Z stabilizer generators
แล้ว minus one outcomes ชี้ให้เรา end points ของหนึ่งหรือมาก chains ของ adjacent X errors และเราสามารถพยายาม correct
errors เหล่านี้โดยการจับคู่ minus one outcomes เข้าด้วยกันและสร้าง chain ของ X corrections ระหว่างพวกมัน และ
ขณะที่ทำสิ่งนี้ มันสมเหตุสมผลที่จะเลือก shortest paths สำหรับ corrections ของเรา ตัวอย่างเช่นถ้าเรา measure
syndrome เช่น อันที่แสดงที่นี่ เราสามารถเลือก path ระหว่าง unhappy tiles และ apply X
gates เป็น corrections ตาม path นี้ แน่นอนว่า chain จริงๆ ของ errors ที่ก่อให้เกิด syndrome อาจ
ต่างออกไป เช่น อันที่แสดงที่นี่ แต่ไม่เป็นไรตราบเท่าที่ errors และ corrections ด้วยกัน
อยู่ใน stabilizer อาจเป็นไปได้ด้วยว่า corrections ของเราสมบูรณ์ loop รอบๆ
torus ซึ่งไม่ดีเพราะในการทำสิ่งนี้เราก่อ logical error ดังนั้น strategy ของการ correct
ตาม shortest paths correct low weight errors แต่อาจไม่ทำงานสำหรับ higher weight errors แต่แน่นอนเราไม่สามารถ
คาดหวังอะไรมากกว่าจาก quantum error correcting code ใดๆ อาจเป็นไปได้มากกว่า ขึ้นอยู่กับ noise model คือ
เราสังเกต minus ones จำนวนมากใน syndrome และในกรณีนี้เราสามารถใช้ efficient classical algorithms เพื่อ
จับคู่พวกมันและหา lowest weight error ที่แสดง syndrome ตามที่ฉันพูดถึงในบทเรียนก่อนหน้า
สิ่งนี้อาจไม่ correct explanation ที่น่าจะเป็นที่สุดสำหรับ syndrome เสมอไป แต่มันทำงานค่อนข้างดีโดยทั่วไป
และ succeed เสมอในการ correct errors ที่มี weight น้อยกว่าครึ่งหนึ่งของ distance L อย่างเคร่งครัด และฉันควรยัง
บอกว่ามี strategies อื่นๆ ที่เหมาะสมกว่าสำหรับ error models ต่างๆ มันผ่านไปกว่า 25 ปีตั้งแต่
toric code ถูกค้นพบ และในช่วงเวลานั้นมีงานมากมายเกี่ยวกับ quantum error correcting codes รวมถึง
topological quantum error correcting codes อื่นๆ ที่ได้รับแรงบันดาลใจจาก toric code รวมถึง codes ที่อิงจาก
แนวคิดที่ต่างออกไป ฉันไม่สามารถให้ comprehensive list ของ code constructions ต่างๆ ที่รู้จักทั้งหมด แต่ฉันจะ scratch surface
นิดหน่อย และพูดถึงตัวอย่างที่รู้จักกันดีสองสามตัวอย่างย่อๆ ก่อนอื่น ปรากฏว่ามันไม่
จำเป็นจริงๆ ที่ toric code มี periodic boundaries กล่าวคือเป็นไปได้ที่จะตัดแค่ส่วนหนึ่งของ toric code และ
วางราบบน two-dimensional surface แทนที่จะเป็นบน torus และสิ่งที่เราได้จากการทำนั้นเรียกว่า surface
code ตัวอย่างเช่นถ้าเราตัด edges ของ lattice ตาม pattern ที่แสดงที่นี่ที่มี rough edges ด้าน
บนและล่างและ smooth edges ด้านข้าง และสอดคล้องกันเราใส่ edge cases สำหรับ stabilizer generators
แล้วเราจบลงด้วย code ที่ encode แค่หนึ่ง qubit ครั้งนี้ แต่ code ยังรับ most
important characteristics ของ toric code โดยเฉพาะ non-trivial undetectable errors สำหรับ code นี้ต้อง
สอดคล้องกับ chains ของ errors ที่ extend จาก left edge ไปยัง right edge หรือจาก top ไปยัง bottom
ขึ้นอยู่กับว่าเป็น chains ของ X errors หรือ Z errors ตามลำดับ ยังเป็นไปได้ที่จะตัด
edges ในแนวทแยงเพื่อได้สิ่งที่บางครั้งเรียกว่า rotated surface codes และการทำนั้นสามารถเป็นประโยชน์สำหรับการทำ
codes ประหยัดมากขึ้นในแง่ของ qubits ที่ใช้ ตัวอย่างเช่นถ้าเรา take surface
code นี้และทิ้ง qubits บางส่วนออกเหลือ square ที่วางในแนวทแยง เราได้ surface
code อีกตัว ตราบเท่าที่เราระบุ stabilizer generators บน boundary ในแบบที่ถูกต้อง diagrams แบบนี้ช่วย
ให้ชัดเจนว่า stabilizer generators define อย่างไร ที่ black tiles รวมถึงอันที่โค้งที่ edges ชี้ X stabilizer
generators และ white ones ชี้ Z stabilizer generators อันบน boundary โดยวิธีเป็นแค่ 2-qubit XX
หรือ ZZ stabilizer generators ครั้งนี้ และคุณจะเห็น diagrams เหล่านี้หมุน
45 องศาบ่อยๆ อีก class ที่น่าสนใจของ codes ซึ่งยังอยู่ใน general category ของ topological codes คือ color
codes ฉันจะไม่อธิบายว่ามันทำงานอย่างไรโดยแน่ชัด แต่วิธีหนึ่งในการคิดเกี่ยวกับมันคือมันเป็น geometric generalizations
ของ 7-qubit Steane code ดังนั้น พิจารณา 7-qubit Steane code และสมมติว่าเราหมายเลข
qubits ของเราโดยใช้ quket ordering convention ตามที่แสดงที่นี่บนหน้าจอ เราสามารถเชื่อม seven
qubits เหล่านี้กับ vertices ของ graph ที่แสดงที่นี่ และสิ่งที่เราพบคือ stabilizer generators match up
กับ tiles หรือ faces ที่สร้างโดย edges ของ graph และสำหรับแต่ละ tile เรามีเสมอ Z stabilizer
generator และ X stabilizer generator ที่กระทำ non-trivially กับ qubits เหล่านั้นโดยแน่ชัดที่พบที่ vertices ของ
tile นั้น ดีตรงที่เช่นเดียวกับ toric code เรามี geometric locality สำหรับ code นี้ ดังนั้นเราไม่ต้อง
ย้าย qubits ระยะทางไกลเพื่อ measure stabilizer generators และ fact ที่ว่า Z และ X stabilizer generators กระทำ non-trivially บน
sets ของ qubits เดียวกันพอดีเสมอก็ดีด้วยสำหรับเหตุผลที่เชื่อมโยงกับ fault tolerant quantum computation ซึ่งฉัน
จะพูดมากขึ้นในบทเรียนถัดไป color codes คือ quantum error correcting codes ที่ generalize
pattern พื้นฐานนี้ ที่เราทำสิ่งเดียวกันโดยพื้นฐานยกเว้นด้วย graphs ที่ต่างกัน ตัวอย่างเช่น นี่คือ graph ที่มี
19 vertices ที่ทำงาน นี่ให้เรา code ที่ encode 1 qubit เป็น 19 และบังเอิญมี
distance ห้า สิ่งเหล่านี้เรียกว่า color codes โดยวิธีเพราะหนึ่งใน conditions ที่จำเป็นบน graph คือ faces สามารถ three-color ได้ หมายความว่า
เราสามารถ color faces ด้วยสีสามสีและเราไม่เคยมี faces สองอันของสีเดียวกัน share edge สี
ไม่สำคัญจริงๆ สำหรับ code เองเราแค่มี X และ Z stabilizer generators สำหรับแต่ละ face ไม่ว่าจะสีใด แต่สี
ปรากฏว่าสำคัญสำหรับการวิเคราะห์วิธีที่มันทำงาน ดังนั้นนั่นคือสอง
code families ที่รู้จักกันดี แต่มี constructions อื่นๆ อีกมากที่รู้จัก รวมถึงอันที่อิงจากแนวคิดคล้ายกับ code families เหล่านี้
รวมถึงอันที่แตกต่างอย่างสิ้นเชิง ตัวอย่างเฉพาะของ quantum error correcting code ที่เพิ่ง
ถูกค้นพบโดยเพื่อนร่วมงานบางคนของฉันที่ IBM รู้จักกันในชื่อ gross code ซึ่งตั้งชื่อนั้นเพราะ gross คือ dozen
dozen หรือ 144 โดยเฉพาะ code นี้ encode 12 qubits เป็น 144 qubits และมี
distance 12 ฉันจะไม่อธิบายวิธีที่ code นี้ทำงานในรายละเอียด มันคล้ายกับ toric code ยกเว้นว่าแต่ละ
stabilizer generators ตอนนี้เกี่ยวข้อง qubits เพิ่มเติมสองตัวที่อยู่ห่างออกไปนิดหน่อย มันไม่มี planar embedding
เหมือน surface code แต่มีสิ่งที่เรียกว่า biplanar embedding หมายความว่าต้องการ qubits สองชั้นแทน
ที่จะเป็นหนึ่ง มันอยู่ใน family ของ codes ที่เรียกว่า bivariate bicycle codes และสิ่งที่น่าทึ่งเป็นพิเศษเกี่ยวกับพวกมันคือ
มันมีประสิทธิภาพมากกว่า toric code หรือ surface code มาก ในแง่ที่สามารถ encode qubits ได้มากกว่าในขณะเดียวกันมัน
ทนต่อ error rate ที่ประมาณเท่ากัน สำหรับ gross code ต้องการ qubits เพิ่มเติมอีก 144 qubits สำหรับ syndrome
measurement ดังนั้นจำนวน qubits ทั้งหมดที่ต้องการคือ 288 ซึ่งทำให้มันเป็น promising candidate สำหรับ technology ปัจจุบัน
และนั่นสรุปบทเรียนนี้ซึ่งเกี่ยวกับ constructions ของ quantum error correcting codes รวมถึง CSS codes, toric code และ
ภาพรวมของ quantum code constructions อื่นๆ รวมถึง surface codes และ color codes หวังว่าคุณจะมาร่วมกับฉันใน
บทเรียนสุดท้ายของซีรีส์เกี่ยวกับ fault tolerant quantum computation ซึ่งจัดการกับความท้าทายของการ perform
computation บน encoded quantum states โดยใช้ operations และ computing components ที่ตัวมันเองมีแนวโน้มที่จะเกิด
errors สวัสดี